all right a good
deal of attention right now to the 1.9
trillion stimulus plan
um well that's not something you can do
through executive order
um but it is something that joe biden
wants to see happen
on by hooker crook uh even if it means
that this is what some democrats are
telling
are going up through without the
traditional venues for example needing a
simple senate majority to make it happen
rather
uh than the 60 usual votes that you
would need in the senate to make
something like that happen
the president meanwhile seems to be
saying but that he's all for working
with republicans but no ifs ends or buts
this thing is going
to happen uh david spunt following all
these developments right now
on where it stands regarding republican
support
david hey neil good uh good to be with
you this morning weekend number two for
president biden he's keeping a low
profile
at least publicly here at the white
house but aides tell fox news he's
constantly
in contact with members over on capitol
hill to try to get something through
both democrats
and republicans neil it was one year ago
that president trump started having
briefings on kovid 19.
monday will be february 1st and last
february is when former president trump
did such a thing the president who spent
more than three decades president biden
walking the halls of the capitol says he
plans to pass a package
with or without the help of republicans
remember democrats neil have the upper
hand
running the senate the house and the
white house but the president says he
wants to do things in a bipartisan
manner first
if not so be it
i support passing cover relief with
support from republicans if we can get
it
but the cover relief has to pass there's
no if ands or buts
no ifs ands or buts the speaker of the
house nancy pelosi will bring a
resolution to the floor
to get the president's 1.9 trillion with
a t dollar relief package kicked off
after the house passes it which is
expected remember the democratic
majority will go to the democratic-run
senate
technically there are 50 democrats and
50 republicans in the senate however
as per the constitution the vice
president kamala harris will be the
tie-breaking vote and you can expect
she'll vote to pass the measure
senators to watch neil this is who all
eyes are on capitol hill the moderates
like retiring senators
pat toomey and rob portman also joe
manchin
and susan collins house minority leader
kevin mccarthy has several republicans
who
are in favor of passing such a measure
1.9 trillion dollars
after all it was former president trump
a republican who was pushing those two
thousand dollar direct payments to
americans
ultimately the last congress couldn't
get anything done people got 600
direct payments neil the question is
will those republicans that supported
the higher amount under president trump
support the higher amount
under president biden neil yeah i guess
that's a big question david thank you
very very much very very interesting i
want to go right now to republican
louisiana senator bill cassidy on this
senator you probably heard david's
report um hook or kirk we're going to do
this and
uh with or without republicans what did
you think of that
well it's a little bit harder than that
but i think the republicans can be there
but it can't just be spending 1.9
trillion dollars
pulled out of the air with no
justification it has to be what's good
for the country
and partying hard now with a hangover
tomorrow
is not necessarily good for the country
republicans will be there for that which
is good for the country
we need money for vaccinations we need
money to
address these variants coming from other
countries
that's common ground there's other
things that are common ground
republicans will be there but they won't
be there for payoffs
to democratic constituencies or just to
check the box for a
campaign promise the president made
which has no no rationale in terms of
economics
well i know what you have to sing about
you know republicans are not going to be
there for parting hard but no offense to
your fine party sir
republicans oversaw these massive uh
deficits build under president trump
that continued from president obama that
continued from president bush
so both parties spend like crazy
and the pandemic certainly is a catalyst
i get that but are you open to some of
the other ideas that have been banded
about maybe breaking this package in two
and some of the more
controversial provisions like aid to
states and all
put off in a separate in a separate
measure
to be debated after a first one
i'm totally open to that um and
and in fact i'm with the group that's
working on it
i smiled your reporter described pat
toomey as a moderate
i've never heard toomey described as a
moderate
these are people who across the spectrum
conservative to moderate
recognize that there are some things we
can agree upon
i as a conservative as a doctor know
that we need more money
for immunizations more money to build
our capacity to produce more vaccines
we can agree on that we can go forward i
don't agree for 170 billion
for schools when the reason that schools
aren't open
is because teachers unions don't want to
open not because
it's unsafe for the children to attend
science tells us the children can attend
safely
it's the teachers unions who are the
obstacles
by the way you should hear what senator
toomey says about you
um but let me ask you a little bit if i
can
a senator on um the 15 minimum wage that
the president wants to be part of this
package bernie sanders wants to be
part of this package in fact speaking
about bernie sanders he wants it to be a
lot more
than this there's talk about a push
among progressives
of a rolling stimulus check from the
government every year
um do you think that the problems the
president might have might not come from
the right
but from the left i think the problem
comes from his policy
i've never seen an administration start
off deciding to kill jobs
let's kill 11 000 keystone xl jobs like
that
by the way those are folks who don't
make their money on a zoom call
they make their money getting callouses
and packing a lunch
those jobs are gone let's raise the
minimum wage to 15
that restaurant just barely hanging on
now closes completely entirely forever
because their fixed overhead went up so
much in the middle of a pandemic
this is the most anti-jobs program i've
ever seen
no wonder they want generous stimulus
checks because everyone's going to be
unemployed
the best stimulus check is a paycheck
and that's what we should be focused on
not not just putting out all these
dollars for people
that have been made unemployed by
federal government policy
senator bill cassidy very good catching
up with you thank you sir appreciate it
thank you